bom eu começo uma pergunta que na
verdade já foi feito aqui não deixa vôo
vocês se lembram o que vocês respondiam
quando a pergunta era o que você quer
ser quando crescer eu me lembro bem
eu ainda criança eu já queria ser
professora de criança
o tempo foi passando e eu fui crescendo
cada vez mais apaixonado por matemática
e nessa época comecei a ouvir essa
menina vai ser engenheira
então chegou a hora de entrar na
faculdade
eu escolhi engenharia elétrica mas o
semestre foram passando e eu comecei a
sentir que faltava alguma coisa talvez
aquele lado essa menina vai ser
engenheira obra tivesse preenchido mais
o lado quando crescer eu quero ser
professora de criança não estava
e hoje quando eu olho pra trás eu
consigo entender perfeitamente o que
significava uma criança de 7 anos falar
porque a professora de criança estava
gritando naquele momento era que eu
gostava de gente que eu queria trabalhar
com gente mas como que a gente resolve
isso eu tomei uma decisão foi muito
difícil para mim na época que foi
assumir já estava com o cerrado já ficou
claro pra você isso né
então eu comecei a procurar uma
engenharia me possibilitasse unir exatas
e humanas que foi em engenharia de
produção
mas mais do que isso eu entrei para uma
ong chamada engenheiro sem fronteiras e
juntas essas duas decisões foram
responsáveis pelo equilíbrio
eu consegui aplicar na comunidade tudo
aquilo que a gente aprende a engenharia
o objetivo principal da ong e eu
consegui desenvolver pessoas trabalhando
na diretoria da ong
e de fato foi perfeito
rapidamente me apaixonei pelo trabalho
voluntário e desde o meu primeiro dia na
organização toda energia que eu tim era
para que aquilo deve cada vez mais certo
ea gente conseguisse atingir cada vez
mais pessoas
eu vou tentar mostrar pra vocês um
exemplo de como que tudo isso foi tão
intenso e transformador pra mim
em um certo ano a gente resolveu fazer
uma campanha de páscoa
a gente sempre fazia isso a gente
arrecada chocolate leva para as crianças
das comunidades rurais de itabira
ou então para creches e que geralmente
eram pra crianças que a gente sabia que
se não fosse assim talvez não tivesse a
oportunidade de ganhar um chocolate na
páscoa mas nesse ano aconteceu uma coisa
especial na nossa equipe que a gente
começou a observar que tinha muita gente
morando na rua
a gente pensou que a gente vai atingir
sua criança se a gente tem agora um
outro público que a gente também pode
atingir
eu lembro que surgiu na equipe o
questionamento assim será que faz
sentido a gente entregar uma caixa de
bombom para pessoas que não têm
absolutamente nada para comer
acho que não então a gente montou os kit
ea gente colocou água suco biscoito
fruta e também a caixa de bombom que o
intuito era representa a páscoa ea gente
vai entregar quando a gente chegou no
local da entrega a gente percebeu que o
número de pessoas era muito maior do que
o número de equipes e agora o que a
gente faz ea gente pensou vou me
entregar os kits então só para as
crianças ea gente pede que ela
compartilha com as famílias esse kit
nessa hora eu pensei gente as crianças
vão pegar um chocolate não dividir e vai
entregar o restante para as famílias e
tenho certeza que vai acontecer mas em
realidade a linha
na hora que a gente entregou o kit eu me
lembro que uma das crianças abrir o
pacote
a primeira coisa que ela falou fui olha
tem água
eu já contei essa história amigo dele e
todas as vezes que eu conto eu me
emociono porque você olhar para uma
criança que tinha uma caixa de bombom e
uma garrafa de água ea primeira coisa
que ela fez e pega a garrafa de água e
ela tomou logo como se fosse a última
coisa que existe na face da terra e
aquilo acabou comigo eu voltei pra casa
com uma sensação que não tem palavra no
mundo que me permita traduzir e agora eu
pergunto pra vocês
quem foi beneficiado nessa história a
comunidade
eu o meu time e eu respondo a vocês com
toda convicção todos nós e eu acredito
que é nesse momento que o engajamento
acontece quando toda a rede consegue ser
atingida e transformada
mas como isso acontece na prática
vamos por partes eu coordenei um projeto
da ong que o objetivo é a gente
despertar o empreendedorismo em crianças
em situação de vulnerabilidade social ea
gente quer mostrar para elas é a
realidade que elas têm hoje pode ser
diferente amanhã mas isso não significa
em hipótese nenhuma ao induzir essa
criança a sair da comunidade
muito menos induzi la a buscar a riqueza
que a gente quer mostrar pra ela ela
pode ser que ela quiser com a profissão
você quer ser pedreiro eu quero ser
professora quer ser médico não importa
desde que você coloque toda a sua alma e
todo o seu amor naquilo que você fizer
vocês conseguem perceber o poder
transformador que isso tem
quando a gente olha com carinho e com
cuidado com uma criança ensina ela
certos valores incentivar
sonhar ea realizar os seus sonhos a
gente não está transformando aqui só
realidade essa criança a gente está
transformando toda a comunidade em que
está inserida
porque é nesse momento que a gente
começa aquilo que a gente já conhece por
corrente do bem
e é nesse momento que toda uma
comunidade começa a ser transformada em
uma outra uma outra transformação que
acontece a transformação pessoal
imaginem vocês uma roda de crianças de
olhos pequenos
talvez com muito pouco para viver mais
com o coração cheio de sonhos você
entrega para uma folha em branco fala
para ela assim desenha qualquer coisa
que vocês sonho qualquer coisa não
importa
desenha seu sonho elas começam a
desenhar e depois elas vão mostrar para
os colegas relações contar para os
colegas esse sonho algumas falas
brinquedos outra sala televisão e até
uma cama mas chega uma criança e fala
que o sonho dela é que a mãe para o bebê
e que o pai volte pra casa
isso mexe com você
isso mexeu muito comigo porque eu vi
isso de uma criança que naquele momento
estava com uma folha em branco na mão
que ela podia colocar qualquer coisa que
ela quisesse ali material não existente
ou não mas foi isso que ela quer
foi isso que ela sonhou em uma outra
coisa que eu acho muito curiosa nesse
processo de desenvolvimento pessoal com
ele vendo o voluntariado é que ele vem
de todos os lados
uma pessoa talvez cruza o seu caminho
apenas uma vez na sua vida e que nunca
mais cruze de novo ela transforma
e talvez ela jamais saberá disso
e foi o que aconteceu em uma campanha
que a gente fez arrecadação de alimentos
em que a gente saiu pelo centro da
cidade pedindo doação de alimentos e
depois a gente levou pra zona rural
a gente chegou em uma casa que por sinal
era muito muito simples ea gente
perguntou para a moradora se ela
aceitava a nossa doação de alimentos
ela olhou pra gente falou assim vocês
estão me doando o me pedindo doação
a gente falou a gente tá aqui do ano se
a senhora quiser aceitar a gente está
atuando
ela falou eu posso doar a última
pergunta que eu esperava ouvir claro e
ela fala de seu pacote de macarrão
entregou para a gente ela falou o
seguinte há pouquíssimo tempo atrás eu
não tinha absolutamente nada para comer
e graças a deus a receber ajuda
hoje eu tenho pouco mas o pouco que eu
tenho é o suficiente para dividir com
alguém que precisa mais do que eu e mais
um pedacinho de mim foi transformado
eu comecei a olhar o meu redor coisas
que antes não observava eu comecei a
sentir a dor do outro doente e hoje eu
tento olhar para cada pessoa que cruza o
meu caminho como um ser único especial e
ainda tem uma outra transformação que
acontece quando o engajamento vêem como
um todo que a transformação do nosso
time da nossa equipe
se você me perguntar hoje qual foi a
frase que mais falei
nesses meus quase cinco anos na ong eu
te responderia nem pensar
nenhum voluntário deve sair daqui sem
ser transformado
ele tem que ser transformado tanto pela
experiência que ele vai ver a comunidade
quanto pela transformação que nós como
organização
vamos proporcionar a ele e toda vez que
a gente encerrar o ciclo a ong a gente
dava um espaço no final para que todos
os voluntários que quiserem expressar
alguma coisa palavra qualquer coisa que
eles quisessem
a gente sempre ouve alguém falando sobre
o quanto foi transformado nesse período
tinha gente que falava que jamais
imaginava
liderando uma equipe que descobriu que
era apaixonado por isso quando teve a
oportunidade de coordenar alguma outra
equipe
a gente escutava pessoas falando que
antes tinham sônico do microfone de um
pânico de falar em público e que
descobriram que são apaixonados com isso
quando começar a dar palestras sobre a
ong ou então quando começaram a falar
sobre educação financeira uma sala cheia
de gente mas ainda tem uma outra
transformação que acontece que enche meu
coração de esperança à nossa equipe
começa a incorporar o voluntariado com
um estilo de vida e esse é o ponto
a gente costuma pensar erroneamente a
beleza do voluntariado passando pelas
coisas são mais difíceis de fazer
construir uma casa sabe o dia de amanhã
para fazer arrecadação de alimentos mas
não a beleza do voluntariado está na
pessoa em que você se torna a beleza do
voluntariado está em você deu seu lugar
no ônibus
ensinar para alguma pessoa aquilo que
você sabe mais do que ela olhava uma
pessoa que sente fome e aquilo realmente
o em você e você fazer alguma coisa para
ajudá la
é muito simples mas muitas vezes a gente
não consegue fazer isso porque a gente
não está conectado com o mundo já
pararam para observar como a gente vive
no automático
a gente levanta de manhã vai trabalhar
volta pra casa e no dia seguinte a gente
começa tudo de novo
a gente olha
uma inconscientemente a gente pensa isso
não é problema meu mas quando a gente se
reconectar com o mundo
a gente olha para o mesmo problema ea
gente pensa esse problema também é meu a
gente começa a adquirir cada vez mais
empatia roupa e eu preciso conversar pra
vocês
o quanto eu sou apaixonada por essa
palavra
eu acho que a minha palavra preferida no
mundo e empatia ela tem um significado
muito mais profundo do que a gente pensa
é muito mais do que você se colocar no
lugar do outro
é você colocar no lugar do outro
na situação em que o outro se encontra é
diferente de quando a gente fala assim
se fosse eu no seu lugar eu jamais teria
feito isso
se fosse eu o seu lugar eu não teria
deixado a situação chegar no ponto que
chegou
agora ativando a empatia eu não sei o
que eu faria se eu tivesse no seu lugar
e vendo as coisas que você viveu e sendo
a pessoa que você mas eu me solidarizo
com você e eu estou aqui para te ajudar
perceberam a diferença quando a gente se
reconectar com o mundo a gente faça
entender que eu só estou aqui eu só
existiu porque você existe
eu só sou porque nossos há pouco tempo
atrás e fizeram uma pergunta me pediram
para escrever num papel
a resposta pra isso qual é a sua missão
no mundo
e eu pergunto pra vocês
qual é a sua missão no mundo conseguem
responder
naquela época não conseguir eu pensei
pensei
ei uma frustração invadiu mas eu não
conseguir responder eu fiquei pensando
como é que eu não consigo responder qual
é a minha missão no mundo aquela coisa
que faz a gente levantar todo dia de
manhã
aquele negócio que a gente chama de
razão de ser
eu não consegui responder eu deixei a
minha folha em branco hoje um pouco mais
madura e tendo vivido um pouco mais de
experiência
eu consigo entender porque naquela época
não respondi a essa pergunta porque eu
acredito que a nossa missão
somos nós que fazemos a sua missão é
você quem faz é a soma de tudo aquilo
que você já viveu com tudo aquilo que
você já sentiu e com tudo aquilo que
você acredita
hoje a minha folha não está mais em
branco
eu escrevi nela minha missão no mundo é
transformar positivamente
cada pessoa que cruzaram seu caminho e
consequentemente fazer do mundo um lugar
melhor e agora eu pergunto a vocês
qual é a missão que você quer ter no
mundo
obrigada